buen día para ustedes y quiero
preguntarle qué tanto nos podemos fiar
del resultado de estas elecciones para
hacer una proyección del futuro de el
bolsón arismo
buenos días en general buenos días a los
telespectadores
no se puede decir nada sobre el bolsón
arismo hasta porque es un abismo de
hecho no existe no existe un liderazgo
de verdad el presidente de la república
para que se imprima esto a las a los
comicios de 5.510 y 70 municipios que
tenemos acá así que por ser en como muy
distintas las elecciones de la relación
que tenemos de entre municipio y
ciudadano y ciudadano y federación lo
mismo gobernación son relaciones muy
distintas esto hace con que de hecho muy
poco de verdad un presidente de la
república acaben primero su liderazgo su
proyecto de vieja de liderazgo sobre el
país como un todo
de esta manera tan directa así que no se
puede decir mucho sobre el futuro de
bolso nada en especial para 2020 dos de
éstas
las elecciones obviamente que estas
elecciones son como algo un uno de los
espacios donde se definen aspectos
institucionales lo que va a ser las
elecciones
digamos generales elecciones
presidenciales y gubernamentales de 2022
pero todavía no es una relación directa
entre presidente y municipalidades bueno
justamente una de las ciudades uno de
los estados donde ha encontrado bastante
oposición bolsonaro es en sao paulo
además de esta ciudad de río pues son
las dos ciudades mayores de brasil y una
segunda vuelta
usted diría que nos muestra en un
fenómeno de fuerte polarización en el
país sabiendo que aquí pues hay una
población muy muy grande de brasil
bueno el bolso ha perdido en muchos
sentidos de nuestras elecciones podemos
decir por ejemplo habían como más de 90
candidatos con el apellido bolsonaro y
esto hizo con que de estos tantos
noventa y tantos candidatos sólo uno que
su hijo ha ganado por tener apellido es
algo muy distinto de lo que pasó a dos
hace dos años atrás con las elecciones
presidenciales bueno esto es un punto el
otro punto que nos apoyados por
bolsonaro tampoco están bien o tampoco
fueron tan lejos
digamos que escríbela el actual alcalde
del río y que tal vez y debería ser
apoyado por por versionar también no es
el favorito de la contenta del río de
verdad lo que pasó en río y son paulo
son cosas que no podemos atribuir
solamente a la polarización un tren
favor bolsonaro derecha izquierda lo que
estamos midiendo por ejemplo el frío son
dos fuerzas de derecha
ah
a la disputa de más en una vuelta